hey everybody welcome with live coding
with Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're
gonna do some testing so got a few
comments in the chat already so you
think it's just everybody saying hi hey
everybody if you're just joining us for
the first time we are building a game
just a really basic children's game to
help them learn math we're building it
in react native web which means we use
react native syntax and then it gets
turned into a web app this may seem a
little bit strange why not just use
react well if you do it like this then
you could use the same code base for a
web app and a mobile app so that's why
we're doing it like this if you want
more explanation check out some of the
earlier streams like maybe like day 1
and 2 and then I go in a lot more detail
about why we're doing it like this
alright so this is the way the stream
will go I'm gonna start a Pomodoro timer
so 25 minute timer during that 25
minutes I'm gonna focus mostly on the
code and just narrate when the timer
goes off I'm gonna go to the live chat
and answer questions so if you have a
question just hang in there I will get
to it at some point
I do read everything in the chat so I'm
not I'm not ignoring it just trying to
get some get as much done as I can
early on when I started streaming I
tried to keep up with the chat as I was
coding and really quickly it became
apparent that I would get nothing done
if I kept on interrupting my
my train of thought for the chat okay
great we have some viewers there was a
little lag on these statistics and it
looked like nobody was watching for a
while all right I do want to point out
see our pool requests yeah so we have
full requests that have not been merged
so I do want to merge these pool
requests first before we get started so
some of these like the add the license
is awesome I can just Auto merge this
I'm not gonna have to test it we can
just check what files changed and we've
added the license that's the only thing
that changed it's always important to
include a license with your open source
work that lets people know if if they
can use it how they can use it I always
try to get that into your project as
early as you can so I'm just gonna merge
that confirm that merge and write a
little thank-you note if you're
maintaining open source project I think
it's really important to always thank
people even if you end up not accepting
their their pull request it's it's still
you know they put in work so cart cart
okey thank you so much I'm not sure if
you're watching right now or not but I
really appreciate that
let's check out the other pull requests
we had this is add submit on enter key
for us so this is awesome I kept
mentioning that I wanted to implement
this and then just never never got
around to doing it so this was good for
this one too I'm just gonna check the
files because it should be a really
simple change so yes it's on submit six
inputs
once I change on submit' editing
actually that's really interesting I
don't know so who did this fool request
let's see Abraham if you're watching let
me know I'm not familiar with this like
the on submit editing I'm like I'm not
saying it doesn't work but I'm just not
familiar with it so I'm gonna go ahead
and since this is such a simple change
I'm gonna merge it and we'll just test
it like on the fly normally if these
were more extensive change I would
actually pull it down as a separate
branch and then test it and then decide
whether or not I'm gonna merge it but
for very small changes like this
especially on a little side project like
this I don't really have a problem
merging merging these as is let's merge
this as well all right so now that
should be in the code we still have some
open issues so let me close these
because these this one is closed now
let's close that and then this one is
that on submit enter key press you can
see that's that's been merged there
let's just verify that this is working
so we'll do a get pulled so you're gonna
get pull and we should have if we have
the changes and so now let's check our
app and see what happens
mmm let me do a hard refresh and just
see okay cool
great yeah so we we do have a submit on
enter key and that's really cool
I definitely want to look into how you
did that because up until this point
let's see our FJ s so we have our press
here so what I had done before was like
instead of this on submit editing that's
Wow okay that's cool that must be built
into react native let me see basically
it says basically on submit editing will
trigger an event provided when the Go
button is clicked from an Android soft
keyboard nice okay so this is intended
to work with the Android soft keyboard
but when you're doing it on the web it
actually submits on enter that's awesome
I have some other stuff I'm working on
that I'll probably refactor to use this
now because otherwise I actually just
would track the key press and see like
if it was the Enter key that would press
that would submit but that is excellent
that's really awesome that's what I love
doing this the show because I learned so
much like even little things like that
which you know when it comes to the code
it's gonna reduce my codes slightly but
you know I use that a lot of places so
like overall it's gonna have a cool
effect and it's also gonna enable
functionality on mobile with the same
code so web and mobile will share the
same code which is pretty awesome so
thank you so much for that
well that was Abraham that I yeah I
think that one was over him so awesome
so let's go ahead and close that as well
okay cool
yes so now we just have one open issue
I'm sure we'll we'll add
you that I already I talked with it was
someone on Twitter about some other
things that need done and I need to make
issues for those as well but today we
want to focus on testing right so in
particular I'd like to set up some
end-to-end tests these will definitely
work with the web version I'm not
exactly sure how the test would work
with mobile so once we end up doing a
mobile build then we'll think about the
test for that but right now since we're
only worried about web we're just gonna
go with with the web stuff yeah so
here's what what I'd like to use is
puppeteer okay to do a headless Chrome
browser and then so basically you know
it will mimic what the user is doing so
I'm gonna open on another screen I'm
gonna open up a package JSON file that I
have on another project and to remind me
of everything that I need to install all
right so let's go with
here's what we're gonna go with for our
installation we're gonna do a yarn add
and then we're gonna give it this D flag
which means it's gonna be added as a dev
dependency a dev dependency is not going
to be included like in your your build
right so things you don't need for the
program to run to actually run you can
put in your dev dependencies and then
that will decrease the size of your
build but people who clone your repo
will still see like okay I need these
for testing or whatever you need these
for it so I'm gonna do chai mocha Oh
mocha puppeteer and I think that's it so
we we don't we're gonna use jeff's but
we don't need to bring in Jess because
[Music]
just is built-in with create react app
so since we use create react that we
already have just in fact if I would try
to add just create react app would give
me a message in the console saying like
hey we've detected different versions of
gest and so we're just not going to
address but and we're also gonna add
enzyme now enzyme is from Airbnb I'm not
sure what the status of that project is
Airbnb is moving away from react native
so that may not be kept up to date but
for what we're gonna use it for it's
going to be fine but there just keep
that in mind though that may be a good
idea to find a replacement for enzyme
but I'm used to using enzymes so at this
point I'm just I'm gonna go with it
and I'm expecting that at some point
I'll probably have to figure out
how to do stuff without using enzyme see
these are just gonna install the
packages while that's happening we can
add in to our package JSON another let's
see so we're gonna add in another script
right so react scripts this this is what
create react app comes with already has
its test okay so we're not gonna use
that I'm gonna make another one that I'm
just gonna call e2e all right because
we're gonna these are going to be our
end-to-end tests and then in our
end-to-end tests I'm going to this is
gonna be a lot so we're gonna run mocha
and we're gonna give it a timeout
all right so that'll be like 30 seconds
to the timeouts in milliseconds we'll
give it 30 seconds right now that should
be enough for what we're doing depending
on how many tests you have like it may
you may want a greater timeout but for
now I think this should just be this
would be fine and then we're going to
set up some files but I'm gonna call
these files right now so we're gonna end
up having a folder called
e to e and run rjs so we're gonna split
out some of our testing into separate
files so we're gonna start this up from
our runner J s file and we're also gonna
do and we're gonna have a tests folder
and then anything in that test folder
that has the suffix of dot speck dot J s
we're gonna we're gonna run those tests
so this is basically the this is our
command
we're running mocha with a timeout of 30
seconds
okay we're using our runner J's file
which you'll see that in a second and
then we're gonna have our anything in
our test folder with this suffix is
gonna run as a test so let me save that
oops
failed to save okay let's I'm gonna cut
that for a second and just close this
don't save let's reopen this so as these
were installing it made changes to
package.json so we could see we have our
dev dependencies now so that's why I
gave me that message so let's just add
that back in and save now if you didn't
see that message was just saying there
were newer changes that were made
so there was it was like conflicting
right all right so now we have our dev
dependencies we have this setup or NN
test now we need to actually bring in
our tests so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go to a previous project that we
did on on this show so I believe maybe
this was like project 5 or something I
can't can't remember for sure but I'm
gonna go to my github and let's go to a
4 let's go here I believe I had it set
up here yep so we have a test folder
here and you can see whoops no that's
not it those are unit tests here's our
NN test so we're gonna grab our setup
from this project and this will save us
a lot of time since we already have it
set up and then we're gonna use that so
I'm going to open these so we can just
copy and paste very quickly and we'll
just grab like one of these just to get
some boilerplate so now let's see runner
you'll notice I don't know if Harshit is
watching right now this morning I
haven't seen him in the chat but har
should set these up initially on this
project so thanks again to harsh it for
doing the initial setup on these on
these tests these NN tests ok so this
will be a runner J s file so you can see
this is just basic setup right like
we're requiring browser and options
which will see those files in a second
and then we're just starting it up and
closing it down right starting up our
headless browser closing it down in it
it's nice to have it in this file
otherwise we would have to do this like
before and after all
our tests so this just this saves us
some work all right so let's go back to
here and let's set up our our folders
right so we want a folder called e to e
inside e to e we want to add a file
called runner not runner dot j s and
we're gonna copy that in okay
let's go back here and do yeah just
close this so no I don't need it this is
our browser yes
okay so let's copy this we'll go over it
in a second I found out about being able
to do these multiple desktops on Windows
so I need to get used to the the
shorthand keys for that so I think it's
like Windows control is that it no
that's not it
the window control
maybe I don't have my hotkeys set up
if anybody knows about how to do these
different desktops on Windows let me
know um but I definitely don't have it
down so far I wanted to just work just
like it does in Mac but I haven't gotten
that down all right so let's verify this
was browser ejs so let's create that
browser Duchess and we're gonna copy
that in it so in browser dodge is right
where we're requiring puppeteers is
where we're bringing in puppeteer right
and then we're we're setting this up
right so this is just like the
boilerplate that you need to set things
up we pull in our options which we will
have an options file for that right so
this stuff like once you have it set up
you'll probably never change it so this
is the only time we're ever really gonna
look at these files and our last one
our last setup file will be oops did I
forget to do I think accidentally closed
options options yep there we go
okay the options is the the easiest file
to figure out what's going on options J
yes okay so in our options J ass week
we're setting our app URL to local host
right which we're gonna test locally
we're running our project on localhost
few thousand so obviously you change
this to whatever you need it to be and
then we're gonna run this in headless
mode if you set this to false you'll
actually see a browser pop up and you'll
see stuff happening in the browser which
is kind of cool to look at but if you're
doing these tests like constantly it
gets annoying after
so I usually just set it to to true and
leave it set to true I don't know we may
do like one test run once we get some
test setup where we have it set to false
just to see also if you're having
trouble with your test sometimes just
looking at what's happening is a good
way to debug I actually did that
yesterday is having some issues where
the tests were - hanging at one point
and after I ran it not in headless mode
I could see exactly what was happening
and it helped me to debug the test so
there are times when you would run
actually see what's happening so let's
close these out now that we have them
set up let's make our our actual tests
folder oops that's not it want to make
it inside here so tests and then inside
tests let's add our first test if you
get some comments in the chat in about
four minutes I'm going to go back to the
live chat and answer your question so
hang in there so we're gonna have to
change this a bit I don't remember
what's going on in this test from the
last project so it may actually work I
think it may just be testing to make
sure that something loads on the page
oops so we're gonna make this what did
we call this one page dot spec touch is
yeah let's just call this one app dot
spec jeaious it was that yeah suspect
and that will paste this in here and
let's look at what this test is actually
doing so were required we're pulling in
this expect from chai okay so we see we
use it down here and we'll get that in a
second
we're also pulling in tests from our
browser file right so what we're doing
is so let's say I don't want a page to
let say describe this is I'll just put
some in there for now and for now it
says page can be seen at slash page and
I'm not gonna say slash page I'm just
gonna see at slash right so just at our
home and so we're gonna start our tests
we're passing in our browser and our
options okay so now we are loading a new
page right it's a new page and that this
everything going on in here is kind of a
mix of stuff you can do with puppeteer
with chai with Jess
so it's like it's very with mocha so
when I do this I usually have to have
like four different documentation pages
open but once you get like a few tests
written you can usually just modify copy
and paste and modify your test as you go
along so now we are actually going to
let's get rid of this because we want to
go to the home page right so this is
gonna be our URL from our options which
is localhost 3000 now we're creating a
constant to hold the value of body right
so or it's just going to be the string
body okay and we're gonna wait till we
find the selector body on the page right
so HTML pages all have right like body
let me check my timer all right one
minute and we'll go to the chat and then
now we're creating a constant
innertext so what we're doing is we're
evaluating the page okay and we're
looking for all of the inner text that's
inside of body right the body tag on the
page right so this is not gonna give you
HTML it's just gonna give you text
that's on the page and in this case we
want to make sure that 404 which would
be a 404 error does not show up anywhere
on the page so all this test is doing is
saying that something loaded when we
went there like something other than a
404 error happened when we went to this
page so this is a very basic test but
it's not saying much really not much at
all
but this test should run it should work
so let's let's test out the test here
and let's say yarn e2e let's see what
happens okay so our test is running home
screen can be seen at slash and so we've
passed our test it took one second total
so they round it up so it's kind of nice
it shows you all the tests that you
passed and it'll tell you how long each
one took and then it'll give you a
report of how many you passed and how
many failed so that's our first test it
has limited usefulness as it is now but
we will add on some more tests that will
be a little bit more useful and
hopefully that will give us confidence
to be able to make changes and we'll run
our test and be sure if our tests pass
that our changes have not broken
anything we also if we have time we
might set it up so that the tests will
run automatically when you try to commit
and you won't be able to commit unless
the tests pass so I think that's kind of
cool to setup there we go here's my
timer all right so I'm gonna take a
short break I'm gonna go to the chat
and I'm gonna start way up at the top
and try to get through as many questions
as I can and I also need a drink okay
all right so I'm gonna skip through all
the the hellos but I'm just gonna give
one big hello to everybody that's saying
hi okay we have a request Ravi says
please make a video on JavaScript and
angularjs I am NOT I have very little
knowledge of angularjs so I'm probably
not the best person to make that video
but we do I think we do have some
angular videos on the free code camp
channel here so check those out let's
see
Katt Karr Karr Zeki
I'm not sure pronounce your name so
please let me know how I should
pronounce it but anyway they say thank
you for merging EPR oh you're welcome
thank you for submitting the PR that was
super helpful III definitely appreciate
it I always get so excited when I see
that pull requests are being merged I
need to put more issues in so that
anybody that wants to work on the
project will know what with the ads so
maybe I'll try to do that today and if
you all think of some issue or some
feature or see a bug or something feel
free to put an issue in the the github
repo as well
[Music]
Michael Carrillo said and now the wait
for puppeteer to install it actually
installed really fast so if I was trying
to do this stream on my laptop it that
would have been the end of the stream
like it would have just the frames
framerate would have dropped like it
would taken forever but on this new
machine like I'm I'm very impressed with
my new my new PC so far and its
performance while streaming
all right michael lenz says what is
react used for react is used for
creating hmm sorry about the yawns react
is used for creating web apps like
single page applications progressive web
apps but react native which is what
we're using can also be used to create
mobile apps basically that you you can
create a wide variety of things with
react because it has the ability to
render to four different platforms so
your javascript HTML type code can be
transformed into something that can be
run on a variety of devices and
platforms so it's very very cool so I
mean that's a very like short summary
and leaves out a lot but that's
basically what reacts what I use react
for then Dan Juma says fYI for your
information react also builds VR apps I
have seen that and I'm I really really
want to build a VR app at some point so
maybe that can be one of our next
projects maybe we could have battle my
VR who knows but I definitely want to
try that out
O'Town says the screen is blurry ok let
me know is anybody else having a blurry
screen on my end like all the analytics
are saying the stream is fine on my end
but let me know it should be I should be
putting out 1080p so if your connection
can handle it you should be getting a
1080p stream right now Aniki says have
you tried cypress for end-to-end testing
I have not tried Cypress but I'm
interested in hearing more about it
James lark says sir please tell me what
should I choose software dev or web dev
for better job opportunities it kind of
depends on your area and what's in more
demand so
I guess it really does depend like I
don't know where you're at or which
where you're looking at - you actually
get a job but there are a ton of jobs
either way web dev software depth and
really like the line between a web dev
and a software developer are so blurred
now with things like like a web
developer could create a desktop app or
a mobile app using the same tools they
used to do web apps right so it's the
line is very blurred so you probably
could learn the same skill set
essentially and get a job doing either
one okay so we're saying alt tab yeah
let me try this actually for segue we
have this up here so I can alt tab and
see these screens okay what I want to
try to do though is do let's see what I
want to do is be able to do a shortcut
to just automatically switch to another
desktop so like I can tab and I can see
like there's two desktops here but I
don't want to even see it like I want to
get to the point where I can just do
like wait a second did that no that's
not it that's what I did last time and I
the guy that sits next to me at work
yesterday was we were messing with it
and trying to figure it out and I think
he was able to do like windows key
control and then arrow keys and it let
him switch but it's not working for me
right now let me see maybe windows alt
windows shift
yeah it's windows shift that's it okay
awesome so Windows shift lets me go back
and forth
this is actually weird it's it's
changing both of my screens though
that's weird all right so I don't want
that I need to look into this more so
what it was doing was when I'd switched
so like right now on the screen and you
all can see that I'm in the code but
when I press window shift arrow key it
shows this screen but on my other screen
it's now covered up my my streaming
software and it's added the code over
there so I need to mess with maybe the
settings or learn more about that but if
you've ever used a Mac it's very easy
like to go between your desktops so I'm
trying to like get that same ease of use
on Windows because I'm just so used to
it for my Mac all right but anyway let's
write some tests so I'm gonna mark down
here where I left off at in the chat so
I can come right back to it 7:53 looks
like a good place 53 okay
so I'll come right back to there and
continue on with a live chat after we do
another Pomodoro session yeah so I may
not do this entire session I just would
like to get one act like additional
tests written and then try it out so
let's see let's go let's go back here
and let's think about like what we would
want to test so right now this is
basically saying can we see we expect it
not to contain a 404 all right but
that's not really like potentially
that's not telling us a look is the the
page could not show anything really and
this test would still pass right so
let's add something
that's going to give us a little like
better indication of what's actually
gonna happen on the page so let's expect
inner page to contain and I believe we
have the word battle math here so let's
expect it to contain battle math right
[Music]
and let's see if that if that passes
right so not only do we not want a 404
error but we wanted to say battle math
okay really if if it says battle math we
probably don't need that 404 so let's
just get rid of that right so I want to
know like not only like is there
something there but is there this title
there which should be there on all the
pages
let's see run this oops there we go
okay so that passes now still took about
the same amount of time actually a few
milliseconds less than the last time so
now I I think I'm no expert in testing
right but I think this is a little bit
of a better it tells us more right it
says hey we went to your home page and
the title of your app is actually
visible at your home page right so if
this test were to fail I know something
is definitely wrong with my app so I
broke something for sure okay let's try
to make another test so we can copy and
paste this it right and we can make a
completely new test here so we could say
let's look at our app for a second and
say what what else let's restart it see
what our basic thing is like what else
would we want to see on the page and if
we didn't see it on the page it would
definitely be a problem right so I guess
I mean we would want to be able to see
on the very first page like a hero
and three enemies
[Music]
let's just let's do one for now let's
let's say we can definitely see a hero
character on the page we'll keep it
really basic right so what would do is
in our app dot J s we need to give our
hero an ID so that we can pick them out
on the page right so we have our hero
right now is just a view right
eventually this will hopefully change
and it won't just be a square but for
now it's a square so normally we could
just put an ID here but in react native
what we want to use native ID so
actually with react native web if we
just wrote ID it would work okay but it
won't work with wet like you know it'll
give us at least I think it'll throw a
warning at some point that we we can't
use IDs or something like that so it's
been a while since I did that but I do
remember getting some sort of warning
about that so anyway the react native
way to add an ID is with native ID so
let's just say hero right and usually
you remember I mean this is like basic
HTML stuff but you only want to have one
ID on the page so they they have to be
unique so there should only be one hero
on the page one hero ID okay when we get
down to enemies what we'll probably want
to do is instead of an ID we would want
to use a class or we would want to give
each a unique ID but saying something
like the ID equals enemy and then like
the iterator so it'd be enemy like zero
enemy one enemy two right so it's just
whatever you get the ID can be whatever
you want but it has to be unique
let's see oops I meant to go back to our
test all right so now that we have that
what we can do is we can say let me grab
let me go back to my other screen here
and see some of the other tests that
I've I've set up so what we can do is we
can check for the HTML so let's do one
where we actually check for the inner
HTML so let's get rid of this for a
second and can we get rid of this too I
believe we can yeah so let's get rid of
all this and just so kind of a different
way to do this so right now we're still
getting our page
all right we're still awaiting like
we're gonna go to that home page but now
let's do a let result we could probably
make this a constantly Const : stress
all in general it's good to use Const
unless you really need to use something
else
so we're going to just call this a
result we're gonna say await page dot
eval so we're gonna do evie al Evo and
then we're gonna evaluate body so
remember last time we actually made a a
Const for body selector for body right
now we're just gonna skip that and just
say body right and then inside here as
our second argument that we pass to to
eval right we're gonna put a function
right so we're gonna say
I'm gonna do an arrow function so we're
gonna dot e dot inner we're gonna do
HTML this time instead of text so what
this will do now is before we just had
the text right so we couldn't for
instance like verify that there was an
input on the page with this or anything
this is just giving us the text now
we'll actually be able to see things
that are in the HTML in the mark-up of
the page so we'll be able to do
something like we expect the result to
contain and we could say close hero now
normally the hero would not show up
under text right because that doesn't
actually display as text in the page
it's it's an attribute of an HTML
element that but now we should be able
to see that so let's save that and run
our end and test see if we've done it
correctly yep
so we can see that title battle math
oops and I forgot to change this so
let's change this to visible at slash
and hero let's say hero can be seen as
slash let's change it up so keep it keep
it the same
so title can be seen at slash hero can
be seen as okay so now we'll just see
like in our testing we'll get better
messages see title hero so it's good
that to give these good names so
describe you can give like the name to
the the whole group of tests that you're
doing and then under the
that each its you can give a name to
each one of these a descriptive name to
what you're testing then when you see
like a test will fail it'll be a lot
easier to figure out what you need to
look for to fix it
if you give nice descriptive names here
alright let's see how much time I have
I'd like to do at least one test where
we actually like do something on the
page so let's see we need to do a little
bit of setup in our app dot J s so in
order to get things from the page let's
see what we're at ok so right now we
have inside this text we have our value
our operator and our value too but
that's gonna be hard for us to get
access to in our test what we really
should have is we should have IDs for
each one of these right so let's let's
do that let's switch this up and let's
put let's separate these out so that we
have three texts and let me verify that
our styles won't get messed up by this
Styles thought math text where our style
that up here okay you know what I'm
actually I'm gonna move these styles
down below because I just I like moving
them down below so that this first stuff
that you see is more like the actual
like logic of the component so I'm just
used to that if so that's what I'm gonna
use for my projects there's nothing
wrong with put them up top that's just
what I've been used to like I said I
just like to see as soon as I see the
component first thing I'll see is like
the functions the logic I'll scroll down
I'll actually see the mark up and then
the Styles at the bottom because usually
the Styles tell you the least about what
the component actually does is just my
experience so our math text all it has
is a font size and a padding right so
we're gonna get rid of that padding
right because we don't want that
everywhere right so let's get rid of
that padding right and let's make sure
we put that on the view itself where's
the bathroom there actually you know
what we can put that on the text input
so we have styles input so we had a
input input input
oops I thought I had the there we go
what was that again and padding right
there we go
okay so we're to move this and make it a
padding left
or better yet let's make it a margin
left okay all right so now the input is
gonna have a margin left right which
should take care of this so now we can
actually copy and paste our text here
without worrying about weird spacing
happening okay so now we're gonna have
text
oops totally messed that up I wanted to
do is get rid of these and this and for
this one we'll get rid of that and then
actually I guess we'll need another one
for our equals there we go
alright so first off let's see if this
even displays properly a it does we're
missing some spaces but that actually
looks okay I may like that better
without the spaces not I think about it
I get I yeah I kind of like that I'm
gonna leave it without spaces for now
but now what this will let us do is add
native IDs so we can have a native ID
for each one of these and our native ID
will be like let's just say Val about
one and then for this one
we'll make it about two for this one we
don't need anything and for this one
we'll just say operator all right so we
have that now our input needs a native
ID let's say native ID equals answer
let's say answer input
let's keep the same answer input okay so
normally like everything we're doing is
like camel case but generally like
within the Dom you would usually use
your your hyphens for things like
classes and ID so that's what I'm kind
of keeping this because this is gonna
end up being in the in the Dom right
okay
I think that's all we need you know what
let's put this I native idea on this as
well native ID equals we'll say this is
submit all right great now when we come
back to our test this will make a bit
more sense when we actually write out
our test right so let's say can submit
and submit answer let's see then we need
a way to check
and see not only can't submit let's just
say like correct answer reduces enemies
by one okay so if we actually test this
this is gonna tell us a lot about our
application so this is an ambitious test
right it's gonna take a couple of steps
but that's what I want to try to do let
me see all right seven minutes it's
gonna be rough to get into seven minutes
but we'll see what I can do so we're
still gonna go to the home page right
and we are going to actually let's do
one more thing if we're going to see
where the enemies are we need to give
the enemies so at least classes right so
let's say class name right so in react
we need to use class name because in
JavaScript class is a reserved word
right so we're gonna say class name and
let's say enemy since there'll be
multiple enemies we need to use a class
instead of an ID okay so now we need to
have the user have some type of action
right so for that we can say we can use
our our type right so we already have
our page element right so we could say
page dot type and this action literally
means we're going to type something into
the page so the first parameter that we
pass in here is going to be the ID of
our the place where we want to type so
our input so this is going to be the
answer
input so we're going to type in our
answer input and inside the answer input
let's what we're gonna type answer right
but I need to create that so let's
create answer answer is going to equal 1
[Music]
how we gonna do this one plus let's just
do it for us to I 1 plus file - correct
addition so for this one I'm just gonna
test addition okay so correct addition
that'll make it just a little bit easier
since we're running out of time
correct addition answer should give us
Val it should be Val 1 plus Val - right
so let's do Const 1 and cost of 1 is
going to be see how I can get I think I
can get let's see I might be able to do
it like this
this might be overkill I may not need
all of this but let's see so instead of
body if I eval the ID Val 1 and then
instead of innerhtml I get inner text
this should give me that value and
JavaScript should be able to handle the
fact that it's getting this as a string
but it can it'll know that like I want
to add these numbers at least I think
that's that'll be the case we'll know
really quickly if that's not the case
okay so now we're grabbing value 1 and
value 2 and I'd like to actually see
that is there some way I could do this
without like faster or maybe an only one
line but for now this I think this will
work so we'll get the values we'll get
the answer here and then we should input
the answer right then after we input the
answer we're going to why is my my
indentation is so messed up the input
the answer now we need to click the need
to click the button so for this click
let's say I think we can just do a page
click so we can do need to do I need to
do a wait so I forgot oh wait here let's
do a wait I need to fix all this
indentation page click and then this is
going to be our submit write we named it
submit ok so after we do this click
now we can see the result we can
evaluate our HTML right and we wanted to
contain and here's where I may have to
look this up let's see what time it is
okay only have one minute no okay
we may have to we may not get finished
with this but let's see expected to
contain and let's see I think this would
be in jest there we go
fine select find a number of render to
child confounders children no child
support for counting all child elements
all right let's just let's try the first
ones to know that much time so fine
selector to have length of nice okay so
we can I do to have length of excellent
so we should expect it to have length of
two right so let's just grab this whole
thing now I don't want wrapper I don't
want to have to use wrapper okay
let's try it with contains my time is up
rapper dog continues
all right I need to get out of this
shallow wrapper because I'm not using
the shallow shallow wrapper selectors
static rendering no I'm not using render
I'm using we're only using one thing
from enzyme what is it expect that's it
or no it's not even from enzyme we're
requiring that from chai what the heck
am I using from enzyme nothing I'm not
using anything I don't even need enzyme
sorry I got confused at the beginning I
use enzyme for unit testing stuff not
friend n testing yesterday I was doing
the last two days I've been doing unit
and end n test so apologies for getting
that mixed up what I need is chai or not
let's see yeah let's see if I can do it
with fun number of elements before for
counting child elements let's see yeah
let's just find this
there we go expects here's this rapper
again to have length of let's see if I
could just use this without the rapper
thing okay so you want to expect our
innerhtml to contain expect results look
this up call children you know what
we're gonna have to do a part two of our
react testing so next time we're gonna
do part two because I'm out of time
here's what I need to happen though so
let's leave a little comment in here so
we know where we left off at so at this
point I need to let's say there should
only be two elements with the class with
the class enemy okay so that's what we
need to check for let's get rid of I
guess we'll leave it in for now but I
mean that's not we know we have to
change this right so what we have so far
is our we're getting our values we're
adding our values we're putting that
answer into the input we're clicking
submit then we should check to make sure
that when we've clicked submit we've
taken away the enemy so it starts by
default with three enemies so now there
should only be two enemies left so we
should we need to figure out a way to
check how many elements on the page have
the class of enemy and that should be
equal to two if it's equal to two our
test passes if it's not equal to two our
test fails so that's the next thing we
need to do let me do a
that is all so I think we can do a yarn
remove you wanna remove enzyme did we
add yeah so we'll get rid of enzyme now
but I've realized that I messed up and I
don't actually even need it okay and now
we can do a get add we'll do a git
commit em and we'll say add tests for
homepage do a get push okay so now all
of this is available on the repo if you
want to check it out submit a pull
request whatever it's there now I'm
going to try to answer as many questions
as I can and I will have to end I can't
let this go too long cuz I got a I got
to start work so but I'll see how many I
can get through and 753 okay so we left
off at 753 alright so the question from
talent scout seven seven is what program
is that that he is running Visual Studio
code I think that's probably what you're
asking about
Nimbus as is the secret to coding
practice yeah absolutely
practice practice is like you got to do
it you're not going to be good unless
you practice right even more so than
anything else like you should be
actually coding more than you read
tutorials online videos books like
whatever the thing that will help you
more than anything is practice when you
get stuck then go to the tutorials and
the books and everything and like as you
get more confident you'll probably be
spending more and more time coding and
then just using the other things as a
reference there's nothing wrong with
doing the reading and stuff you can't be
coding all the time but the thing that's
gonna level your skills up more than
anything else is actually coding trying
to figure things out working through
problems
Michael Cruisers I'm thinking of doing a
project with geolocation any
recommendations for packages I don't
know any packages are fan because
because the the browser has the
geolocation stuff built in assuming
you're going with a browser if you're
going with mobile I'm not sure so you
may not even need a package you may be
able to just directly call the the
geolocation like from the window object
so I would check that out first and see
now I mean I don't know about backwards
compatibility but with let's say older
browsers but at least with newer
browsers you should be able to get that
geolocation straight from the browser
API O'Town says I cannot see the letters
at all on the screen very blurry and I'm
sorry let if did anybody else have that
same issue
I mean it's if it's okay for everybody
else then it's it may be your connection
out of town which I'm sorry if that is
the case I could try to make the phone a
little bit bigger
let me know if you think if anybody
would like the font to be bigger I'll
try to do that next time
see
Tech from 5th s how long can it be and
is this a full tutorial usually I go for
about an hour and it's not really a full
tutorial this is more just kind of a
code along where like everybody kind of
not only watches me code but helps code
either through pool requests or through
suggestions in the chat and we just kind
of code a project together I do my best
to explain things though but I wouldn't
exactly call it a tutorial
Master says test the test and Nikki
replies who watches the watch it's
somebody's laravel with a question mark
I have never used laravel so I don't I
don't know very much about it
we have react or angular I mean oh I
know reacts pretty well and I know very
little about angular so I'm going to
choose react obviously like objectively
which one is better I don't really know
I guess it depends on what you're trying
to do and what skills your team already
has Master says what's the difference
between web dev and software dev
honestly there's very little difference
now because of the fact that web dev is
moving so much towards progressive web
apps that that act like web applications
that you can actually use something like
electron to make it a desktop
application like the line between
software dev and web dev is is almost
non-existent now so I would say there's
very little difference but maybe there
I'm sure there are other point of views
that they probably you know would have
some good arguments the other way
the show says I want to know about C
programming I don't know very much about
C programming myself so I probably can't
help you there
C
four caches are you testing react web or
native okay so the testing that we're
using actually is works for react on the
web so like this would work for normal
react right because we're we're starting
up a browser and we're testing what's in
the browser so this would not work then
for a react native mobile app so once we
go to deploy this on mobile then we'll
have to add other tests like another
testing solution for mobile so it is the
case that when you do this you can share
a large amount of code but there are
certain things that you probably have to
implement for each platform right so
routing is one thing that you probably
have to implement more than once because
of the way mobile handles routing versus
the browser and then obviously your
testing is especially your end-to-end
testing like if we were doing unit
testing maybe you could keep the same
ones but and then tests or something
that you're probably gonna have to
implement twice so that's a good
question
political world war news has helped me
code what do you need help with master
says might I ask what is the purpose of
tests basically the tests are there so
that you can be confident like that if
you make it so if you write your tests
well any change you make to the code if
you change something and then you run
the test and they all pass you can be
sure that your change has not broken
anything so it just gives a confidence
so for a little app like this you could
say like oh I could just manually test
it myself well you could but for a
larger app and over like the long term
you're gonna spend a lot of time
manually testing but if you automate
your testing like we're doing here you
don't have to actually do the tests
yourself it's a good idea to still do
them occasionally but you don't have to
do them with every change instead you
run the tests and we're actually going
to make the test run automatically when
we change stuff so it'll be even easier
and then you'll know automatically
before you try to deploy or anything
like that
whether or not you've broken something
let's see Kris Bennett says what game
are we making and he also say stop
cheating off your other computer it's
not cheat at some point I actually
figured out how to do these tests I'm
just not going to refigure them out on
the stream that it seats I'm actually
I'm looking at my own code just on
another screen basically the game we're
making is just a very basic math game
for for young children learning how to
do like basic math and starting with
addition did I say Michael Creole just
said hero be seen at I think I messed it
up title can be seen hero be seen that I
messed that up alright there we go
there's a good there's a good pool
request right there and a fake
my my improper grammar here you'd catch
on that Chris Bennett Bennett says that
actually looks pretty decent not gonna
lie
are you acting are you talking about the
game or the code or the test I said
which which should I use next Jas and
react yes
when should I get to use use neck chat
next Jas if you need server-side
rendering let's say for like search
engine optimization purposes if you need
that server-side rendering I highly
recommend next Jas it will handle so
much of the stuff for you that's
generally kind of complicated so
definitely use it for that if you have
no need whatsoever for server-side
rendering then you might be better off
going with create react app the only
other thing that that's really big that
next gives you is a built-in routing
system so it may be also good like if
you don't need the server-side rendering
but you just you also like don't want to
mess with doing your own routing then
maybe use next as well but I love next
j/s definitely an awesome awesome tool
Chris Venice is is react J a similar to
angular there are some similarities I
would say see Chris Bennett says I need
to learn how to use Linux only familiar
with Windows and Mac yeah I mean Linux
the cool thing is if you know a lot of
the commands for Mac like in the
terminal they're the same as they are on
Linux so like if you're gonna set up a
Linux server a lot of the commands to
get around in the terminal will be the
same
Oh actually they say
alright I'm gonna have to finish I might
not get to all the questions here I
might have to finish up because I gotta
go to work but how about this if I
didn't get to your question put it in
the comments to the video and I'll try
to get to it or you can wait til the
next dream which will probably be Friday
morning and I'll get to it then but
thanks so much the next stream we'll
finish up with this test and maybe add
some more yeah so be looking out for
that hopefully Friday morning right
around the same time like 7:30 or 8
o'clock a.m. Eastern Time
so thanks so much yeah until Friday I
guess have a great day
a couple of days and I'll see you then
thanks again bye